То сонце, то хмари з градом.
Небо над Почаївською лаврою – наче ілюстрація
бурхливих подій між Москвою і Константинополем
через надання Україні томоса.
Тут, у Лаврі, живуть і служать понад 200 ченців
Української православної церкви Московського патріархату.
Скрізь охорона, яка пильно стежить за кожним кроком знімальної групи Deutsche Welle.
УПЦ МП дозволила знімати лише святині,
заради яких тисячі прочан з’їжджаються сюди з усього світу.
Але спілкуватися в жодному разі ні з ким не можна.
Тож запитання, чи мають намір у Почаєві
переходити в єдину помісну Українську православну церкву
і чого очікують у разі надання Україні томоса,
нам вдалося поставити вже за межами лаври.
- Нічого не думаю.
Як дадуть…  Є керівництво церковне, тоді буде щось говорити...
Що буде, те буде, як Господь дасть.
Мати трьох дітей Ксенія щопівроку їздить з Полтави
до Почаївської лаври. Так хоче ії середня донька
Ангеліна, яка час від часу проходить тут послух.
- Я коли сумую за Почаєвом, якщо я дуже хочу сюди, то я хворію.
І дівчина, і мати розповідають, що не дуже розуміються,
що таке томос та навіщо він Україні.
Родина давно зробила свій вибір.
- Мої батьки ходили в храм МП.
Не думаю, що слід з політичної точки зору  оцінювати…
Це вибір кожної людини.
Більшість парафіян, з якими DW спілкувалася тут біля Лаври,
навіть і не думали кудись переходити з Московського патріархату,
навіть попри агресивну політику Росії щодо України.
- Я як ходив, так і буду ходити.
В Московський патріархат.
Політика не грає ніякої ролі. Росія, не Росія.
Це є віра. А те, що війна на сході - це таке...
Більшість мешканців міста Почаїв час від часу ходять до Лаври.
Щонайменше 20% городян з нею безпосередньо пов’язані:
одні працюють там, інші отримують замовлення від ченців.
Створення єдиної помісної церкви та
майбутнє Почаївської лаври – усе це їх, звичайно, турбує.
- Негативно. Щоб його не давали.
- Українська церква вже давно повинна бути незалежною.
Але ми не повинні забирати  власність Московського патріархату
або перепідпорядковувати ії українській православній церкві.
Вони –  це вони.
І хай до них, хто вважає за необхідне,
на приход іде.
- В нас є і українські церкви, в нас різні є.
Ми ходимо в церкву, віримо в Бога.
Щоправда, де саме в Почаєві храм Київського патріархату,
знають не всі. У часи Віктора Ющенка
Київський патріархат все ж домігся від місцевої влади
виділення клаптика землі на виїзді з Почаєва.
Тут, у Свято-Андріївській церкві,
отець Роман служить останні 8 років.
- Парафія невеличка.
Самі розумієте, Київський патріархат в Почаєві…
Так, в неділю 15- 20 чоловік на службі.
По великих святах  може бути і до 30 чоловік.
Отець Роман каже, що навіть із томосом
кількість парафіян навряд чи збільшиться в рази,
адже один храм Київського патріархату -
не конкурент Почаївській твердині,
другій на розмірами православній святині України
після Києво-Печерської лаври. Тож служителі
УПЦ Московського патріархату, ймовірно,
молитимуться тут ще багато років, адже фактично
весь цей комплекс приватизований.
Ще за прем’єрства Януковича його передали
з державної власності юридичній особі
під назвою "Почаївська Свято-Успенська Лавра".
Проте отець Роман все ж дуже чекає на томос.
На думку священника, цей документ багато чого змінить для самих вірян.
- Врешті-решт, щоб Московський патріархат перестав нам закидати,
що ми не канонічні й не благодатні.
Цей томос повинен поставити крапку над тим,
хто є Українська православна церква в Україні,
а  хто є Російська Православна церква в Україні.
Тутешні ЗМІ пишуть про наміри ченців
вивезти з лаври цінні речі, появу людей
з агресивними написами про релігійну війну
та про можливі зіткнення прихильників "руського міру"
з українськими націоналістами. В самій лаврі
посилили охорону. Але місцеві депутати запевняють,
що правоохоронці постійно моніторять ситуацію.
- "Русскій мір" в  Почаєві це такий, скажімо так, фантом,
який по факту не існує.  Є люди, які себе до того відносять,
але ні до місцевої влади,
ні якимось чином на політику, на життя місцеве
не впливають в Почаєві. Я б не сказав,
що "русскій мір" проти бандерівців. Якщо можна так сказати,
то бандерівці в Почаєві зацікавлені в тому,  щоб тут був мир та спокій.
За словами Тараса Паляниці, Почаївська лавра –
національне надбання України. І тут, в ідеалі,
мають служити представники об’єднаної помісної церкви України.
Отець Роман не певен, що в Почаєві варто на це сподіватися.
Але серйозні зміни, за його спостереженнями, вже почалися.
Принаймні тут, у Кременецькому районі Тернопільщини,
вже 6 парафій московського патріархату перейшли до Київського.